look out over there
it's the 1998 American Godzilla movie ah
this free play
it's terrifyingly bad oh I cannot bear
to watch it lay waste to my favorite
film franchise Oh
curse you director Roland Emmerich wait
what is this another Godzilla produce
can this new film atone for the
devastation that has come before or will
it to reduce the skyline of my heart to
rubble the makers of the new Godzilla
film are taking great pains to Telegraph
to nerds that they have deep reverence
for kaiju cinema if you alienate the
Nerds how will you ever get normal
people to watch your giant monster movie
Pacific Rim did a great job with his
priming the pump before release with
faint news footage fake commercials for
black market
I do organ dealers look for the kaiju
symbol at your local black market today
even blueprints of a giant BOTS in
battle the kaiju 11d hundred the new
Godzilla flag didn't elaborate
installation at comic-con that simulated
it how did you attack on a Japanese city
and it featured iconic props from the
original film the new trailer seems to
say that this movie will completely junk
the classic character design like the
1998 version did oh let us never speak
of it again the new one even has those
classic serrated fins but the best part
of the new movie is the war the
filmmakers uploaded their new version to
SoundCloud so we could savor how it
honored the spirit of the original just
listen and compare the classic
now the new verse scuse me mom I will
call you back most importantly in the
build-up for this new film suggest that
its makers realize that the original
Godzilla wasn't supposed to be camping
their monster was a man in a rubber suit
because they had very little money not
because they wanted the audience to
chuckle the 1954 film was intended to be
a harrowing experience that summoned up
memories will be all too real death and
devastation of World War 2 truly the
Godzilla films teach us that the most
horrible and destructive monster of them
all yes Beca King Ghidorah the
three-headed sight work space dragon
what I dare you to disagree what's your
favorite Godzilla villain besides roland
emmerich let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel